hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in chapters 14 and 15 of seneca's on the
shortness of life we have this wonderful
discussion about how studying philosophy
in a certain way not only you know helps
us out as human beings and makes us
wiser but actually amounts to a great
use of our time and
gives us more time than we would
normally have you could think of it as a
Time multiplier as one of the things
that you ought to invest in to get a
great return not exactly the metaphor
that Seneca uses here but one that makes
sense given the rest of what he says in
the work and it begins with this
observation and it's translated
typically only those who give their time
to philosophy and strictly speaking it's
to wisdom sapientia and vacant now this
vacarei can mean to devote time to to
you know be at at ease be at leisure be
idle and occupy your leisure time with
something so giving your time to wisdom
the time that you actually have
available what is does that do for us he
tells us they alone who do this are at
leisure they have otium right they alone
really live and this is going to go
beyond the typical you know if you're
studying philosophy you're going to have
a richer life a more prudent life a
rational life that's all true right so
in in the sense that we're interested in
time he says not only do they watch over
their own time well Bennett literally
their lifetime or their age their ivome
right so you know philosophy is good for
that and we can see why if we've studied
any philosophy we're not going to make
as many stupid decisions we're not going
to Fritter away our time with valueless
Pursuits you know spending it on things
that we think matter at the time and
then later on we realize don't that's
all true
but what Seneca is saying here goes
beyond this we get into the realm of the
philosophy of time or a branch of
metaphysics in this
and he says that what they do is they
Annex they add literally every other age
every other ivum to their own by
studying philosophy it's not only their
own Lifetime right and he says unless we
prove most ungrateful these most
distinguished founders of hallowed
thoughts came into being for us
now that's an interesting thought too
isn't it Socrates you know in the
present
we would say well he didn't know who we
were going to be but he left behind the
Legacy as did so many other philosophers
according to Seneca
that is our inheritance it's for us if
we choose for it to be that he says for
us they prepared a way of living not
just a way of thinking but a way of
living and if we jump ahead to the very
end where he's you know summing things
up for his friend he says
um those with an act of Interest should
progress to better things what is that
love and practice of the virtues
forgetfulness of the passions knowledge
of how to live and die and deep Repose
so you know philosophy as a way of life
actually opens the door for us to have
much more Life by taking on that of
others he says we're led by the work of
these others into the presence of the
most beautiful Treasures which have been
pulled from darkness and brought to
light now what kind of Darkness are we
talking about the darkness of
forgetfulness
every single generation has to reread
the books read the books themselves for
the first time decide what they're
actually going to spend their time on
otherwise things are way back in the
dark Dusky you know probably uh hard to
access Storehouse but then we bring them
out by say reading Seneca
and we've got access to it and you don't
have to pay a lot for this right except
in terms of your time and so Seneca says
this incredibly optimistic thing we have
this vast span of time that we can range
over he says from no age are weed to
Bard we have access to all and if we
want to transcend the narrow limitations
of human weakness by our expansiveness
of mind there is this great span of time
for us to range over and if you think
about the people that he's talking about
you know centuries have passed sense
many of these philosophers came on the
scene and you know he is as distant from
you know say Democritus as I I suppose
you could say we are from you know Renee
Descartes or even uh earlier thinkers
right so this is worth keeping in mind
there is this vast span of time already
there that we can range over and then
he's going to name a number of different
representative philosophers and you know
in a certain way
were fortunate in that we have hundreds
and hundreds more including this guy
Seneca himself so he'll tell us in this
very famous passage we can debate with
Socrates something that Socrates himself
is known for right entertained out with
carneades carniades is one of the
academic Skeptics and doubt for him is a
very important tool we can be at peace
with epicurus and you might say wait a
second isn't Seneca a stoic philosopher
why is he lauding you know Skeptics and
epicureans well because he thinks that
this is part of our inheritance no
matter what and that epicurus actually
has good things to say we can over we
can uh overcome human nature with the
stoics the school that Seneca himself
belongs to we can go beyond it with the
cynics which is you know a common theme
in cynic philosophy to go beyond what
the average person is capable of doing
all of these
are available to us as ways of life and
not just as you know a list of what we
ought to do but
theories that we can find in particular
texts he also mentions Pythagoras he
mentions Xeno of course the founder of
stoicism a little bit later he says
um
we can talk about xenopythagoras
Democritus so Pythagoras and Democritus
are pre-socratic philosophers he talks
about Aristotle and theophrastus
Aristotle's close friend and successor
and what do we get from these people
well they can be our teachers they can
also be as he says High priests that
might not be that attractive to US
unless we're you know sort of
religiously oriented but we can think of
them as like you know the ones who are
the master practitioners the ones who
are keeping this stuff alive he mentions
them being friends with us which is a
very interesting term he tells us
um
you know that that uh we can have uh
conversation with these we have friends
who advice Whose advice we can seek on
the greatest or least important matters
who we can consult daily about ourselves
who we can hear the truth without insult
and receive praise without fawning and
provide a model after which to Fashion
ourselves right he tells us that they
can be our companions right uh and they
can even be our patrons in in Roman
society the patron client relationship
was quite important we can associate
ourselves with them and this leads to
another really interesting uh idea that
we're going to talk about in a minute
but before that let's see some of the
other things he says he tells us none of
them will be unavailable to us so unlike
going to you know somebody's house and
like knocking on the door can so and so
come out I want to have a conversation
I'm too busy you know or they're sick or
something like that
if we want to know what Plato has to say
we can read Plato anytime we want to I
mean you might say well you can't do it
while you're sleeping obviously right
but you can wake up and then read some
Play-Doh it's up to you what you do with
that if you want to read Seneca we've
got Seneca available if you want to read
uh carniades that's a little bit trick
here we'll talk about the problem of
lost texts in just a minute but we can
certainly find out about carniadis in
Seneca and in people like Cicero right
so we have these things available none
of them he says will let you leave empty
handed provided you're actually not just
going in there and and treating them as
if they're merely your servants or
something but somebody who can tell us
about life about thinking about human
nature
you'll come away maybe not totally
understanding everything but you're
going to gain something in the process
and he has a whole bunch of things where
he says none of them will do X they will
all do y so you know he says None of
these philosophers will force you to die
how are they going to force you to die
but they will all teach you how to die
how to live your life in such a way that
your death won't be a terrible tragedy
none of them will diminish your years
each will share his own years with you
this is where we get to this
how do we get more alive how do we get
more time how do we get more years well
these people share it with us even
though they are dead by our Act of
reading and conversing with them uh with
none of them will conversation be
dangerous friendship life-threatening or
cultivation of them expensive it's in
some respects the least expensive thing
that you can do sitting quietly by
yourself reading Plato or Aristotle and
if you think about our own age that we
live in where all these ancient texts
are available for us on the internet for
free it's just amazing we don't even
have to go to the library we don't have
to purchase something we can read
Aristotle online if we want to and
commune with him in that way
now there are some things as he says
that are up to us these are our
responsibility and he says that you take
literally what you wish and what you
will right so you can take whatever it
is that you want from us and different
people are going to take different
things perhaps at different ages of life
if I think about my own experience over
the last more than 30 years studying and
then teaching philosophy there are
certainly some thinkers that I came to
appreciate and draw upon later than
other thinkers including Seneca himself
he also talks about becoming part of
their
households this is a very interesting
idea he has a contrast here there's a
common saying it was not in our power to
choose the parents we were allotted they
were given to us by chance but we can be
born he says to who whomever we wish how
is that possible
says there are households of the most
distinguished intellects choose the one
into which you'd like to be adopted and
you'll inherit not just the name but the
actual property which is not to be
hoarded in a miserly or mean Spirit the
more people you share it with the
greater it will become for Seneca this
is primarily the stoic school so Zeno
and crucipus and all these other great
thinkers right some of whom he mentions
in his works and in his letters but he's
also willing to become Affiliated or
adopted by some of these other schools
as well and this is a possibility for us
we don't choose our birth parents we may
not even choose our adoptive parents for
example in my case I was very fortunate
in who I got but we can
have ourselves be adopted into whatever
philosophical household we find most
attractive
um now he goes on and talks about this
coming back to the metaphysics of it is
something that opens the path to
immortality he says
this meaning studying philosophy is the
sole means of prolonging stretching out
uh extendedly mortality or rather of
transforming it turning it
into immortality
um now what does that mean we're not
going to die no we're going to die
physically but we can live many many
lifetimes in this life by participating
in wisdom and we might even contribute
to it ourselves Seneca is a prime
example right we're reading what he had
to say about this
Millennia ago and drawing upon that very
wisdom reenacting it
Reawakening it right now as we read and
think about what it is that he's saying
so he tells us you know honors monuments
all these sorts of things these are soon
destroyed there's nothing that the long
lapse of time doesn't demolish and
transform but it cannot harm the works
consecrated by wisdom no age will efface
them no age reduce them at all the next
age and each one after that will only
enhance the respect in which they're
held Envy focuses on what's close at
hand we more freely admire things from a
distance
so the Sage's life the wise person's
life is wide in scope and they're not
constrained by the same limitations that
constrain the rest of us he says he
alone is released from the limitations
of the human race he is master of Ages
like a god or God now interestingly this
master of Ages it's actually that the
ages
serve
serviance in Latin the wise person
they're all resources available there
for him by or her studying the great
minds of the past Who Remain living in
that past available for us as all of
these different functions there is
something that we should bring up namely
that you know Seneca is referencing all
sorts of people that we don't actually
have the works of anymore you know
Pythagoras we just have some fragments
and testimonies same with Democritus
Aristotle we know that we're missing a
significant number of his works we don't
have any of Zeno the founder of
stoicisms works we don't have carniades
we have just a minuscule amount of the
epicureans and interestingly enough of
the stoics
Seneca is the one who we have the most
of all right and he's the late snowing
so what does this do anything to his
contention you might say
um not really in part because we still
do have a lot of Aristotle we do have
access even though we don't have their
text to testimonies of the early cynics
and we do have some things by late
cynics as well we do have some things by
epicurus and we have things by other
epicureans and discussions this
conversation even though texts are lost
we can still participate in it right
maybe parts of the household have been
locked away until we find those texts
but we also
have a vast variety
of other thinkers other texts other
Traditions that were not available at
the time of Seneca which includes his
own Works in these lists but also all
the later philosophies all the other
modes of wisdom that we can participate
in in this way so I think his his point
still holds if we follow him in thinking
that we gain access to more life
by reading studying and conversing with
the great thinkers of the past